this is what would happen if you fell  into the deepest hole on earth  this hole called the cola super deep  borehole is located in northwest russia  and is 12 kilometers deep falling to the  bottom of the hole would take just over  three minutes and you'd be traveling at  a speed of over 175 kilometers per hour  at first you'd find it hard to breathe  as you'd encounter deadly pockets of  carbon dioxide then you'd be met with  temperatures as high as 180 degrees  celsius which would burn your entire  body in just under a second  at that point you'd probably pass out  and get burnt to a crisp but if you're  somehow still alive it wouldn't be for  long you'd eventually smack into the  bottom of the hole and get completely  obliterated  so if you're near here watch out because